reading his meditations we find a person
who is surrounded by Pleasure in a
certain sense although he often writes
from the kind of the trenches of
Germania in in Wartime which probably
wasn't all that pleasurable but he often
talks about how one can be an emperor to
live in a palace and have access to all
these
Pleasures maybe even to enjoy them to
some degree but still to be a stoic
philosopher and still to remain a
virtuous person it's all about not
letting those passions or Pleasures
control you not to attribute value or
goodness to these things in themselves
but still being able to live them you
accept Joy when it comes and you equally
accept sadness and pain when it arrives
but you don't hold on to any of it when
it goes away